PROFESSOR: We're into
chapter 11.
I've asked Ashish to hand out
today a revision of the
previous version of chapter
11, plus chapter 12 on the
sum-product algorithm,
in case we get to it.
I'm giving you a complete copy
of the problem seven solutions
for both weeks, and to get back
on track, we're handing
out problem set eight.
There probably will only
be one more problem set
that you hand in.
All right.
We've been getting to the
centerpiece of the second half
of the course which is codes
on graphs, which is the way
we're going to get to
capacity-achieving codes by
building them on graphs of
linear complexity and decoding
them on the graphs with
iterative decoding.
I frame this in the language
of behavioral realizations.
I say a graph is a realization
of a code via a behavior,
which is the set of
all the possible
trajectories on the graph.
So this is, again, putting it
in system theory language.
I want to distinguish between
two types of variables.
The external ones,
which communicate
with the outside world--
in our case, these will be the
symbols in a code word.
These are the ones that are
actually involved in the code.
So these are more or less
pre-specified for us when
we're trying to realize
a code.
But we can adjoin auxiliary
variables, internal variables,
we often call them state
variables, hidden variables,
latent variables, which are
really there for our
convenience.
They're to make the realization
simpler, or more
elegant in some way, or to have
properties, or whatever.
But these are free for us to
have because they're inside
the box and the world
never sees them.
Now, we describe the behavior by
a set of constraints on the
variables, which in our case,
these are local constraints
that only involves a few of
the variables, each one.
The idea is to express a global
behavior via local
constraints on variables.
And in our case, the constraints
will be expressed
by equations, as we've seen,
or in a little bit more
generality by little codes,
which will go in to make up
this big code.
So in some sense, you can think
of codes on graphs as
being making big codes out of
little codes, making global
codes out of local codes.
The behavior, then, is simply
defined as the set of all
combinations of variables, both
external and internal,
that satisfy all the
constraints.
If we can find a set of values
for all the variables such
that all these local constraints
are satisfied,
then that's called a valid
trajectory, or whatever.
And that's the entire
behavior.
And the code is simply the set
of all external variable
n-tuples that occur as parts
of valid behaviors--
in other words, the projection
of the behavior just onto the
external variables.
All right, so it's an elegant
and rather implicit way of
describing the code, but we'll
see it's very, very powerful.
And last time, we talked
about various styles of
realizations.
I gave you examples of generator
representations and
parity-check representations.
This is really where it all
started, with parity-check
representations, where this
style of graphical
representation is
very natural.
You've got the symbols in the
code, those are the only
symbols you need, and you've
got parity checks, and the
parity checks constrain
the symbols.
If you've got n minus k parity
checks, you get n minus k
constraints.
And it's a kernel representation
in the language
of linear algebra.
It's simply the set of all code
n-tuples that satisfy all
the parity checks.
That's it, we don't need
any hidden variables.
In a generator representation,
this is a more natural
representation, when we're
trying to generate
or simulate a code.
We want to run through a set
of inputs that in effect
create all the outputs,
all the code words.
In this case, we don't actually
see the inputs as
part of the code words,
necessarily.
We might, we might not.
But we distinguish them in this
representation and we
regard the inputs as hidden
variables, or state variables,
if you like.
They're part of the realization,
but they don't
actually occur in the code
words, so they fit into the
hidden category.
OK, and we talked about
two styles of graphs.
Tanner graphs, which are older
and more established.
Tanner really wrote the
foundation paper in this
subject in 1981.
I regard him as the
founder of the
subject of codes on graphs.
However, like a lot of
good papers, his
was completely ignored--
that's almost true--
for 15 years.
And then it was rediscovered
around 1995, when people began
to wake up to this
subject again.
And Tanner graphs really
come out of this idea.
They were closely associated
with that.
We can generalize them
to be more like this.
But it's this simple idea.
We have a bipartite graph, we
make one class of vertices
into the variables, one class
into the constraints, and we
simply tie a variable to a
constraint when it's involved
in the constraint.
And we can generalize it by
making internal and external
variables, which we have
to distinguish in the
picture in some way.
And the constraints, initially,
they were just
zero-sum constraints and
parity-check codes.
One of the things Tanner did was
he said, well, they could
be any codes.
A single parity check is like
a single parity-check code.
And we can make any codes
the constraints.
And the edges don't work very
hard in the Tanner graph.
They implicitly carry the
variables to the constraints
so we could label them
with the variables.
And we showed how a Tanner
graph could always be
transformed to this normal
graph, which I think is
certainly in more complicated
situations, a cleaner way of
explaining things, and cleaner
in a variety of senses.
Here is our taxonomy.
Vertices indicate constraints,
half edges
indicate external variables.
A half edge is something you can
tie to another half edge
to form an I/O pad.
Edges tie together
two constraints.
They're internal, and
so these represent
the internal variables.
And this is cleaner both
analytically--
there's this nice duality
theorem about normal graphs
that I won't be presenting
to you, and a
couple other things.
They're cleaner when you
come to implement
the sum-product algorithm.
I think they're just generally
cleaner, but I may be biased.
I want you to see both because
these still predominate the
literature, although more and
more people seem to be using
this style of graph,
and that's what I
will use in the course.
All right?
So that's a review
of where we are.
OK.
Today we're going to go on to
other important styles of
realizations, and particularly
the next one we'll talk about
is trellis realizations.
So this will tie back to all the
work we did in chapter 10.
And what did we discover
in chapter 10?
The key to a trellis
realization was a
trellis-oriented generator
matrix.
And again, I will put up our
favorite matrix on the board,
the generator of the 8,
4, 4 Reed-Muller code.
And in the form we've come
to know and love,
it looks like this.
And what makes it
trellis-oriented is that all
the starting times are different
and all the ending
times are different.
Therefore these generators
are as short as possible.
The main feature of this
generator that we want to look
at is the spans, the active
parts of the generators, which
we've made as short
as possible.
And let me explicitly write
out what they are.
The first generator is active
from symbol time 0
to symbol time 3.
This one is active
from 1 to 6.
from 2 to 5.
And this one is active
from 4 to 7.
OK, so those are the
active spans.
And we know from that, we can
find the dimensions of minimal
state spaces and of minimal
branch spaces.
OK, we just count the number of
active generators at either
of the state times, which are
between the symbols, or the
symbol times themselves
for the branches.
OK, again, quick review,
especially because we have a
few guests here who we haven't
seen previously in the course.
So that's where we've been.
All right.
Once you have any generator
matrix, or in particular a
trellis-oriented generator
matrix, the code is simply
described as the set of all
linear combinations of the
matrix elements.
And in particular, the code
symbol at every time is a
linear combination of the
matrix elements in a
particular column.
All right, so let's use that to
get a trellis realization.
I've done this in
various ways.
I'm still not satisfied, though
the way that I do it in
the notes is quite notation
heavy and mathematical.
I hope this picture of what
we're going to do is going to
give you a totally transparent
idea of what's going on.
OK, we're going to have
a trellis realization.
Let's write down the
symbol times.
And I'll write them all the
way across the board.
0, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7.
And let me save the
coefficients, ui, here.
And I'll write them as equality
constraints, but you
can also think of them as a
little binary shift register.
I'm going to need u1 at
four different times.
I'm going to need u1 during
its span at time
0, 1, 2, and 3.
So I'll set up a set of
constraints here to propagate
u1 between these three times.
And u1 is going to be an
internal variable.
Strictly, there are three
replicas of this internal
variable here.
And I can pull it out
at each time, too.
So this is where I'm going
to keep u1, in effect.
Similarly, u2 I'm going to keep
around for all the times
that I need it, which
is these six times.
OK, so is that six?
That's only five.
These are all the times that u2
is actually involved in the
output symbols, so I'm going
to have it when I need it.
u3 I need for four times.
I've been inconsistent in
whether I write the variables
or the values of
the variables.
In this case, I'm
writing values.
And finally, u4.
I see I'm going to need more
than one board here.
So now I've got everything
I need at the
time that I need it.
Now, this is going
to be tricky.
I'm simply going to have
a linear combination--
call it g0, g1, and so forth--
which is going to create my
output at time 0, or time 1,
or time 2, and so forth.
And you'll agree from this
generator matrix that the
output at time 1 is some linear
combination of u1.
And the output at time 2 is
some linear combination of
these two guys.
OK, and the output at time 3 is
some linear combination of
these three guys,
and so forth.
You see what I'm doing?
So I could describe these as
simply a linear constraint.
What are the possible
combinations of inputs and
outputs in this constraint?
And similarly--
and don't make me draw
the lines in.
OK, so I claim this is a
realization directly from this
trellis-oriented generator
matrix.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: In this example in
the generator, g has a 0
[UNINTELLIGIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Right.
AUDIENCE: So before, the
component had to be 0 in the
linear combination?
Or are you--
PROFESSOR: I can
do it that way.
Clearly, I don't need this
input at this time.
So I could erase that.
Would that make you
feel better?
Actually, that gives an
even better picture.
It's not going to make any
fundamental difference, but
I'm doing this for a generic set
of generators that cover
these spans.
All right?
For the particular ones we have
here, yes, I can make
that further change and
eliminate those two inputs.
But I'm shortly going to
aggregate this and put it in a
more aggregated form.
And what's happening internally
here then won't
matter to us very much.
OK.
And notice that I can regard
this as the branch
space at this time.
And it has the right dimension
for the branch space at each
of these times.
And let me take it a
little more slowly.
First, I claim it's
a realization.
If I built that thing with
the appropriate linear
combinations here, then the
behavior of this is basically
the set of all u's and y's
that satisfy all these
constraints.
And if I just look at the
outputs, that's the set of all
code words.
So I've constructed a behavioral
realization in a
certain way.
OK, and now I'm going to
start to aggregate.
Aggregate just means drawing
lines around sub-graphs.
Or sometimes in the notes, I
call this agglomeration.
So I'm going to regard all this
as one constraint on the
variables that come
out of this.
The constraints that are
affected by this
agglomeration--
the variables that are affected
are y0 and u1.
OK, so this I can draw--
let me draw it this way--
as a little constraint code
which operates at time 0.
And it's a linear 2, 1 code that
basically ties together
y0 and u1, whatever the
relationship between them is.
It probably is the
y0 equals u1.
The first generator starts
at this time.
That's about the only
thing it could be.
Similarly, I'm going to
aggregate all this part of the
realization here and consider
it a big block, or a big
constraint.
At time 1, there's some
constraint that affects
y1 and u1 and u2.
So this is a little
4, 2 code on the
four incident variables.
One of the constraints is
that u1 on this side
equals u1 on this side.
These are really two replicas
of the same thing.
So there's an equality
constraint
propagating through there.
Then I have some function of y1
as a function of u1, which
I'm going to regard as the
state at this time.
And u1 and u2, let me call that
state space at time 1.
Let me call this at time 0,
let me call this the state
space at time 1.
And I did go through a
development where I showed
that these u's could be regarded
as the components of
the state spaces.
This is a more constructive way
of seeing the same thing.
And notice they have the
right dimensions.
So the states are what carry the
information from time 0 to
time 1, just as we would want.
They kind of embody the
Markov property.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Why is c0 length 2?
PROFESSOR: Why is c0--
AUDIENCE: Length 2.
PROFESSOR: Length 2.
Because it affects two bits.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
PROFESSOR: It affects
these two bits.
Let's see, how did I know that
there's only one possible
constraint here?
Because that's the dimension
of the branch space.
It's really all determined
by u1.
Over here, however, it's
determined by u1 and u2.
So the dimension is 2. u1 and
u2 are free, And the others
are fixed once we know those.
So I was a little ahead
of myself there.
And similarly, let's keep
drawing in this fashion,
here's a constraint code at
time 2 which relates these
possible variables, u1, u2, u3,
which I'm going to call
the state space at time 2.
So my times are not
what I expect.
But it's always really a problem
to keep the indexes
consistent.
We want state time 1 to occur
after the first symbol.
So this should be state time 2,
this should be state time 3
to be consistent with
what's in the notes.
I'm sorry.
And so forth.
What is the length
of this code?
It's simply the number of bits
that it controls, which is 6.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6.
What's the dimension?
It's 3, because u1, u2, u3 are
free if I only look at this
constraint independent
of everything else.
OK, and continuing this way,
at this point, you notice I
only have u2 and u3.
So my state space at time 4 has
gone down in dimension.
And here I have c3, which is,
again, a 6, 3 code, and so
forth, as I go ahead.
Let me just draw it.
This is also a 6, 3.
This is time 5.
I have the state space
at time 6.
This is back down to 1, 4.
It's symmetrical on this
side, as you know.
So that's my trellis
realization.
And I claim this, too, is a
realization, in the sense that
any combination of u's and y's
that satisfy all of these
constraints is a legitimate
trajectory.
And the set of all y's that are
part of those legitimate
trajectories form the code.
In fact, it's pretty explicit
here that the dimension of the
code is 4, corresponding
to u1, u2, u3.
So I have 8 outputs, I have
16 possible behaviors.
I pick off the combinations of
u's and y's that could make
that, which is basically
determined by this matrix.
And I just pick off the y's
and that's my 8, 4 code.
OK, so that's what trellis
looks like.
The constraint code really
embodies the branches.
This encapsulates everything
that can happen at time 0.
that could happen at time 1.
The u's are really
my state spaces.
This constrains state, output,
next state, in nice linear
system theories style.
This tells me what combinations
of state, output,
next state, I can have
at time 2, and so
forth across the board.
So the constraints are
local constraints--
local in time, in this sense--
that constrain what can happen
as you get to the next state.
Once you get to the next state,
this state has the
Markov property.
This is all that the memory you
need of the past in order
to determine the future, or
the whole set of future
possibilities.
Each of these is a linear
vector space
over the ground field.
In fact, it's just the space
of 1-tuples, 2-tuples,
3-tuples, 2-tuples,
and so forth.
And it has certain dimension,
in this case,
equal to its size.
And if you calculate
the dimensions of--
call this the state space,
call this the branch
constraint code if you like,
or the branch space, it's
isomorphic, the dimensions are
minimal here by construction
from the trellis-oriented
generator matrix.
If we want to know the minimal
size of the state space at
time 4 here in the center, we
just calculate the number of
generators that are active at
time 4, and that's precisely
what we're going to get over
there, too, by our
construction.
If we want to compute the
dimension of the branch space
at time 3, it's the number
of active generators
at symbol time 3.
There are 3 active ones, and
we've just forced this to have
that structure.
So this is a normal graph of a
minimal trellis realization of
the 8, 4 code.
OK?
So we can clearly do that
for any code, right?
For any code, we can find a
trellis-oriented generator matrix.
We can go through these steps,
and we'll always come up with
something that looks like
this down here.
OK, now, what are the properties
of this graph?
Does it have cycles?
Does this graph have cycles?
Anybody?
"No," is one answer I get.
What's the other possible
answer?
How many people say no, and
how many people say yes?
I want to see a show of hands.
How many people think this
graph is cycle free?
OK, and how many people think
that it has cycles?
OK, the majority is wrong.
This graph clearly has cycles.
Here are two edges here,
and here's a cycle.
OK, so as a graph, it has cycles
because it has multiple
edges going between
these constraints.
All right, so a good thing
to do is to make this a
cycle-free graph, and that's
just a matter of regarding
this as instead of two binary
variables, we regard it as one
quaternary variable.
All right, so we're going to
regard this as a single binary
variable of dimension one.
This is a quaternary
state space.
There are 4 possible
states here.
So the dimension of the state
space at this time is 2.
So when I draw abbreviations
like this, you can think of
them as being decomposable
into binary
variables, if you like.
But the advantage of drawing
them as larger variables,
higher-valued variables,
is that now does this
graph have a cycle?
No, this graph is cycle free.
I've just gotten rid of all
the possible cycles.
How can you tell if a
graph is cycle free?
Various ways.
I think the most elegant one is
to say if every edge is by
itself a cut-set, then the
graph is cycle free.
If I remove any edge,
then I decompose the
graph into two parts.
And that's clearly true
of this graph.
We don't really have to
test the half edges.
In fact, this is kind
of the defining
concept of a state space.
A state space is kind
of a cut between the
past and the future.
When we asked about the minimal
state space, we asked
what's the minimal dimension of
the information, the state,
that we need to pass from
the past to the future?
And so states correspond
to cuts.
If we make each state space,
if we consider it to be a
single variable, then we get
just a chain graph on a
sequential time axis, as is
conventional in system theory,
as your conventional
integer-time axis for discrete
time systems.
In this case, it only has a
finite number of times where
anything happens.
But you can think of
this as part of the
infinite set of integers.
And so this is everything
that happens.
And a trellis is always going
to be very boring.
It's always going to
look like this.
But the advantage of now we
have this cycle-free graph
realization, we'll find out that
we can do exact decoding
of cycle-free realizations
using the sum-product
algorithm, or the min-sum
algorithm, which in this case
kind of reduces to the Viterbi
algorithm with
an asterisk on it.
And the cost of doing that is
that now have to instead of
considering two binary variables
here, I have to
consider a single variable that
has four possible states.
So basically, I'm going to be
carrying messages which are
vectors indexed by the state
space across here.
And in this case, the vector is
going to have to have four
elements, which are going to be
likelihoods or metrics or
weights of some kind.
It's basically telling me what's
the weight of each of
the four possible survivors,
if you can think of the
trellis that goes with this.
Or here, I'm going to
need to carry a
vector with 8 elements.
So it takes more to specify a
vector with 8 elements than 3
vectors each with
two elements.
So by aggregating these, I've
created a sort of exponential
complexity situation as these
state spaces get very big.
But on the other hand,
I get cycle freedom.
All right?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: There's no real
difference between this and
what you had before, right?
PROFESSOR: As President Clinton
might have said, it
depends what the definition
of "real" is.
What do you mean by
real difference?
I mean, sure.
We think of something u1, u2,
you can think of that as two
binary variables or a single
quaternary variable.
Is there any real difference
between that?
Well, when we actually go to
the implement decoding
algorithms, we'll find there is
a real difference in which
attitude you take.
But mathematically, it's a
distinction with hardly any
difference.
AUDIENCE: So then there's no
fundamental difference between
the cycle freeness
and the cycle--
PROFESSOR: No, you'll see
this real difference--
there is another real,
significant difference.
If I drew this as two binary
variables, I have
a graph with cycles.
And we'll find that I can't
do exact decoding with a
sum-product algorithm on
a graph with cycles.
So if I tried to apply that
algorithm to this, I'd sort of
iterate around this
little cycle.
Whereas if I agglomerate them
into a single variable, I get
rid of that behavior.
And I can summarize everything
in four values.
So in that sense, it's
a huge difference.
AUDIENCE: Can I always transform
this whole graph
into cycle-free graph using
this kind of technique?
PROFESSOR: I didn't get the
first part of your question.
AUDIENCE: Can I always transform
the graph with
cycles to a cycle-free
graph using this--
combining those--
PROFESSOR: Yeah, OK.
So this agglomeration technique
of drawing lines
around sub-graphs and then
considering everything inside
there to be a constraint, and
all the variables coming out--
well, it depends on their
topology, but I can group the
variables coming out
however I want--
yes, I can always do that.
AUDIENCE: So we can always
do that for things
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
transform the graph
into cycle free.
PROFESSOR: Right.
But we may find that to make it
cycle free, I then have to
aggregate all the edges into a
single edge between any two
parts of the graph.
And that may radically increase
the complexity.
And I'll give you several
examples of that today.
So these little fine points
all of a sudden loom large
when we actually come
to build something.
Let me give you another
example of that.
A very fine example would
be to say, what does
sectionalization consist of?
We talked about
sectionalization.
Suppose we want to get a trellis
graph for a 4-section
trellis, where we take
pairs of variables.
Well, the graph realization of
that is simply obtained by
agglomerating pairs of these
blocks, like that.
OK, so let me do that, and then
let me see what I've got.
I've now got here, a constraint
that affects two variables.
Well, first of all, I've now got
only two visible bits in
each of the state variables.
Here I have u1, u2, here
I have u2, u3,
here i have u3, u4.
So we get rid of some of
this state complexity.
We did this trick in another
way before, by
sectionalization.
So we get rid of a lot of state
spaces, including ones
that are big.
Let's see, what do
we have here?
This is now a code which has
got two bits coming in, two
bits coming out.
It's a 4, 2 code.
It's basically controlled
by u1 and u2.
Probably y0 and y1 are
some simple linear
function of u1 and u2.
So this is a 4, 2
constraint code.
It controls these two bits and
these two state bits, these
two symbol bits, and these
two state bits.
What is this over here now?
We've got 2, 2, 2.
So this is going to be
a code of length 6.
And what dimension?
This is, remember, u2, u3.
So this whole behavior here is
affected by u1, u2, and u3, it
has dimension 3.
Or there's a shortcut I can
do here, because this is a
self-dual code, all of
these little codes
are going to be self-dual.
Well, they're not going to be
self-dual, but they're going
to be rate 1/2.
Half as many bits here
as they do here.
But that's another duality
theorem that we won't prove.
OK, and symmetrically, we get
another code here, which is a
6, 3 code, and another
one here.
So we can do this.
The reason I call this styles
of realization is there's
obviously a lot of freedom
in how we want
to depict the code.
And depending on how we depict
it, when we get to decoding
algorithms, it may affect the
complexity of the algorithms.
So we want to find a nice
way of depicting it.
AUDIENCE: I don't understand why
you-- so you want the ...
freedom ... is [INAUDIBLE],
because you would only have
two [UNINTELLIGIBLE] to be
used [UNINTELLIGIBLE].
And then you have two
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
u1 and u2.
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] u2 and 3.
PROFESSOR: There are two
bits here, two bits
here, two bits here.
AUDIENCE: But that's 6.
That's 6.
[INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Weight
6, all right.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] freedom
that you talk about.
PROFESSOR: How many
possibilities are there for
these 6 bits?
I've got to consider all
possible combinations of u1,
u2, and u3 to drive what's
happening in these two times.
If I go back here and look at
those two times, I see that
there are three generators that
I've got to consider,
these three.
All right, so for all eight
possible linear combinations
of those three generators,
I'll get different
combinations of these
six bits here.
And I can go further.
Actually, at the end of the day,
I concluded here, we said
the idea of sectionalization was
to sectionalize as far as
possible without increasing the
branch complexity, which
we've now translated into this
constraint code complexity.
And so it's even better to
just keep aggregating.
Consider the first half.
And this is 1, 2, 3, 4,
two bits there is
still only a 6, 3 code.
And the second half is still
only a 6, 3 code.
When we get to the sum-product
algorithm, that means we have
to compute eight things when
we get to this node.
Maybe it's a slightly more
complicated thing, but as long
as we keep the dimension down to
3, we're only going to have
to compute eight things.
So we haven't really increased
the decoding complexity at all
by doing this.
So that we consider to be our
best sectionalization.
And if we tried to aggregate
these two, what would we get?
We'd simply get the eight bits
here, we get a constraint that
says it's an 8, 4 constraint, it
says these eight bits have
got to be in the code.
So we only go that far, because
that would increase
the complexity to 16.
All right, so that's our
minimal trellis.
We call it a two-section trellis
where the symbol bits
have been grouped
into 4-tuples.
And for decoding, that's
the simplest one.
So you see what kind of games
we can play here.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: At the beginning of
this process, you started at
the [UNINTELLIGIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Well, you remember
in more detail how we
concluded this was the optimal
sectionalization.
We looked at time 3,
in particular.
And we said there are three
generators that are
active at time 3.
So I'm going to expand that as
far as I can without bringing
any more generators
into the picture.
So I can't expand it over here,
because I'll hit u4.
But I can expand it as far
as I want over here.
And that's the way
we sectionalize.
AUDIENCE: So do you always start
with [UNINTELLIGIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Well, there's
some art in this.
Here it's kind of obvious
where to do it.
And I give two heuristic
algorithms in the notes on
sectionalization, which we'll
come up with basically the
same thing.
But for simple codes, you
can just eyeball it.
OK, so let's see.
That's another general and
very useful style of
realization.
It's a trellis realization,
or a sectionalized trellis
realization.
Is there anything else I wanted
to say about that?
We can do it so that we get
minimal branch and state
spaces, or constraint
complexities.
It's cycle free if we aggregate
the states into a
single state space.
Sectionalization, we
talked about that.
OK, so let me leave that up,
because we're of course not
done with that.
Now let me talk about some
general properties of graph
realizations.
And the most important thing I'm
going to talk about here
is the cut-set bound.
I want to get across the idea
that a graph really captures
dependency relationships.
If variables are incident on
the same node, they're
obviously all dependent.
Or if you think of larger sets
of variables aggregated in
this way, then they're
somehow dependent.
Variables that are very far
away on the graph are less
dependent on each other than
ones that are close to each
other on the graph.
This is all kind of vague
and woolly statements.
Let's see if we can make
them more concrete.
First of all, there's a very
simple but important
observation that --
I'll put it this way--
disconnected if and only
if independent.
What does this mean?
If I have a disconnected graph,
let's suppose I have
one graph over here with certain
external variables.
Let me aggregate them all into
y1 and some constraint 1 over
here, and a completely separate
graph, some different
code over here, c2, constraining
some separate set
of variables, y2.
OK, that's a disconnected
graph realization.
It has to look like
that, right?
So we're aggregating the two
disconnected halves.
All right, what can I say?
What code does this
graph realize?
This graph, the code that it
realizes is simply the
Cartesian product
of c1 and c2.
In other words, this means the
set of all pairs, c1, c2, or I
should say y1, y2--
y1, y2 such that y1 is in code
1 and y2 is in code 2.
That is the set of all y1,
y2 that satisfy all these
constraints, right?
So it's a behavioral realization
of a Cartesian
product code.
Now this is really a notion
of independence, right?
This independently realizes a
code word from c1 in this part
and a code word from
c2 in this part.
What would the generator
matrix look like?
The generator matrix from this
would look like a generator
for c1, 0, this is a 0, and
a generator for c2.
So there's a generator matrix
notion of independence.
In other words, these are just
two independent codes that for
some reason, we choose to
regard as one code.
And the same thing is true that
if we have a Cartesian
product code, simply a code
made up of two independent
components, then we can always
realize it in this way, right?
We just realize c1,
realize c2.
So that's elementary, but it
begins to get across the idea
that graph properties have to do
with dependence properties.
And here's the most radical
and simple form of that.
If we have a disconnected graph,
then it really realizes
two independent codes.
Now, more important than that
is the cut-set bound.
What is a cut-set?
It's a set of edges.
Actually, in graph theory, it's
defined in various ways.
It could be vertices,
it could be edges.
Here, we're going to say it's
a set of edges whose removal
disconnects the graph.
Probably there are people in
this room who know more graph
theory than I do?
Does anyone want to quibble
or refine that in any way?
That's my idea of what
a cut-set is.
Any elaboration?
No?
All right.
All right, so we have some
large graph realization.
It's got vertices which I always
draw as blocks, its
constraint codes, they have
various interrelationships.
I'm just showing one.
We have various external
variables that we bring out of
that, and that's the
general graphical
realization of the code.
What are some cut-sets
in here?
I've drawn this, I'm thinking
of this as a cut set.
If I take these two edges and
remove them, then I've
disconnected the graph.
So they form a cut-set.
I've already mentioned the very
close connection between
cut-sets and cycle-free graphs,
which is the graph is
cycle-free if and only if by
removing any single edge, I
disconnect the graph.
So every single edge is
itself a cut-set.
That's a very elegant
characterization.
All right, so I'm thinking
of a cut-set.
I'm going to write it
as chi for scissors.
And it's a set of edges.
So in our cases, what
are the edges?
It's a set of state spaces
for some index set.
OK, so I'm going to select
some minimal set of state
spaces that disconnects
the graph.
All my edges are internal
variables.
We don't really need to worry
about these half edges out
here, as I've said before.
They're always going to
trivially separate their
variables from the rest of the
graph, and it's just tedious
to try to keep them in
the explanation.
So we're only talking about
state-edges here.
All right, once I've done
that, let me now do my
agglomeration trick.
Sorry, I'm trying to draw a
dotted line around a part of
the graph that I'm going to
leave outside the external
variables that I still
want to be external.
I'm going to leave the state
variables, which I'm going to
remember were once connected.
And let me reconnect them now.
So I'm taking my original graph
and I'm dividing it
according to this cut-set
into two parts.
And I'm arbitrarily going to
call this the past, p--
arbitrarily but suggestively--
and the future, f.
And it doesn't matter which one
I call p and which one f.
And I'm going to redraw this,
so this is just a re-drawing
of that in a nicer form.
I'm going to aggregate all of
these variables over here.
And I'm going to call that
the set of past external
variables, y projected
on the past.
And similarly over here, I'll
get the set of all external
variables projected
on the future.
It was just the ones that occur
when I make this kind of
cut through state edges.
Some of the external variables
wind up in the past side, and
some wind up connected
to the future side.
But there are obviously none
connected to both because the
definition of a cut-set.
We've disconnected the graph.
All right, so there's
the past.
There's the future.
And here are the state
variables.
Now I'm going to define these
all together as a super-state
space as I did in the trellis
graph over there.
So let's see, here I labeled the
edges by a set of states.
But what I mean here is that the
super-state space is just
the product of the component
state spaces.
It's elements s chi are just the
set of sj, j, and sigma-j,
is that clear?
In other words, I have a
vector of states here.
And I consider the super-state
space to be just the
Cartesian--
this, again, is the Cartesian
product of
all the state spaces.
OK, and then I have
constraints.
So we'll call this the aggregate
past constraint, and
the aggregate future
constraint.
This constrains these variables
in this state.
in that state.
OK, so that's where figure
5 comes from.
Every year, people say, how
did you get figure 5?
That's how I get figure 5.
Is there any confusion
about that?
Today I've been talking about
agglomeration quite a bit, so
maybe this year it'll
come through better
than in past years.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
that we see projected on it.
Or is it just--
PROFESSOR: It's just the
aggregate of all these
constraints.
What does this say?
It's the set of all the possible
values of these
variables, and these variables
that can actually occur.
That forms a linear space which
we call little code.
Anything consistent with that
satisfies this constraint.
Anything else doesn't.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
for the c's projection of
the code on the past?
PROFESSOR: No.
The projection of the code on
the past would be you realize
the code and you just project
onto these variables here.
So no, this is just an index.
This is a constraint whose
index is the past.
OK, well, all right.
Oh, but this looks like
a trellis, like
a two-section trellis.
It looks very much like
this thing right here.
It has the same general form.
And we can think of this
super-state variable here, it
sort of has the Markov
property.
It, again, tells everything
about the past that is needed
to specify what possible
futures there could be.
We're really interested in these
up here, eventually.
But this is the whole set of
constraints that determine the
futures along with-- there
may be some more free
variables over here.
But these are the constraints
we get from this half of the
code on this half of the
code and vice versa.
So again, a cut-set is related
to a Markov property.
Let me try to state this
property more explicitly.
The code by the behavioral
realization is simply the set
of all combinations of --
let me say, the behavior is the
set of all past states and
futures that satisfy
the constraints.
OK, so this gives me a certain
set of pasts that are
consistent with each possible
value of the state variable.
Let's call that y projected on
the past that's consistent
with a particular value of
the state variable, the
super-state, the vector
of states here.
And these are the ones in the
future that are consistent
with that state variable.
We define that so the set of all
possible past and future
y's is simply this Cartesian
product.
And we say that in a more
graph theoretic way.
If I specify the state here as
some particular value, sx, and
I fix that, I've really
disconnected the graph.
For a fixed sx, I can just
put that over here,
put that over here.
And this realizes, this
connected graph that realizes
the Cartesian product of
whatever -- yp of sx.
This just comes through and
affects that with yf of sx.
So for any particular value of
the state, I have a certain
Cartesian product of pasts and
futures they can occur.
Any past that's connected with
that state can be connected to
any future that's connected
with this state.
All the possible future
continuations of any
particular past in
this equivalence
class are the same.
This should sound very much like
the kinds of things we
were talking about when we did
the state space theorem.
And we get a sort of state space
theorem out of this.
Just to draw this out, we kind
of get a two section trellis
realization where we have the
various states in the state
space here, s0, s1,
and so forth.
We have the pasts that
are connected with
s0, s1, and so forth.
And we have the futures that
are connected to s0, s1.
So we could get from this,
this picture of the two
sectioned trellis.
This really represents a set of
parallel transitions here.
These are all the possible pasts
that are consistent with
that state.
These are all the
futures that are
consistent with that state.
We can tie them together, and
that realizes the code.
I should say explicitly, the
code now is the union over the
states in the state space, the
super-state space of the pasts
there times the futures.
They're consistent
with the state.
So it's a union of Cartesian
products.
And that's expressed
by this diagram.
This is one of them.
This is another one.
These are all of them.
How many are there?
The size of the super state
variable, which by the way is
the product of the sizes of the
state spaces of each of
these individual state spaces
that I had coming across here.
OK.
What's the cut-set bound then?
For linear codes, it's basically
the same as the
state space theorem.
The state space theorem said
that the dimension of the
state space at any time -- well,
let me consider now this
state space, the super-state
variable.
The dimension of this
super-state variable has got
to be greater than or equal to
the dimension of the code that
we're realizing minus the
dimension of the --
this is going to be
bad notation now.
Now I mean the sub-code, so I
should have written something
else for the constraint here.
Minus the dimension of the
sub-code whose support is
entirely on the past, minus the
dimension of the sub-code
whose support is entirely
on the future.
And the state space
theorem still
applies for this partition.
So that gives me a lower bound
on the total dimension of the
states in any cut-set.
So for example, in the 8, 4
code, suppose we have any
realization, so some graph here,
and any cut-set such
that the size of --
I should say the dimension.
I really mean that there are
four external variables in the
past and in the future.
This is dimension, dimension.
In other words, we have four
variables sticking out here,
and four variables sticking out
here, and we have a cut
set somehow going
through there.
So our picture now is going to
look something like this.
What's the minimum possible
dimension of the total
dimension of the edges that
cross this cut-set, the state
spaces that are in
this cut-set.
We know this code
very well now.
Let's do the Muder bound.
What's the maximum dimension?
The dimension of
the code is 4.
What's the maximum dimension
of any code that
lives on the past?
It's 1, because such
a code has to have
minimum distance 4.
So it can't have dimension
greater than the repetition
code of length 4.
So 4 minus 1, same argument
for the future, equals 2.
So it says that however you do
it, you're going to have to
have at least two binary edges
or one quaternary edge
crossing a cut-set that divides
the external variables
into two equal sized parts.
So let's go further.
Let's suppose we want
a cycle-free graph.
OK, if we have a cycle-free
graph, then all of the
cut-sets are single edges.
All right, so in a cycle-free
graph, when we make a cut,
it's through a single edge.
And we're saying the state space
if there's a way you can
make a cut that divides this
into two equal parts, the
state space has to have
dimension 2, it has to have
size 4 for any cycle-free
graph.
Similarly, if we have the 24,
12, 8 code, we've proved that
the minimum dimension of
any central cut has
to be at least 6.
No, in the center, it has
to be at least 8, right?
Yeah, because the dimension of
the code is 12, and a sub-code
that has support on 12 can't
have dimension more than 2.
This can't have dimension
more than 2.
So that would be 8.
So for the 24, 12, 8 code, the
set of edges that cross the
cut have to have total
dimension at least 8.
And if we want it to be cycle
free, then there has to be a
single edge that has
dimension 8.
So the general conclusions --
we first talked about trellis
realizations.
We can generalize that any
cycle-free realization--
and we're going to see that we
have strong motivation to keep
our realization cycle-free,
because then we can do exact
maximum likelihood decoding.
So we'd like to have cycle-free
realizations.
But what have we just seen?
We've just seen that the state
complexity cannot be less than
that of a trellis realization
with a comparable cut.
In other words, one that divides
the past and future in
the same way, divides the
external variables
into the same size.
OK, so we really can't beat the
trellis bounds, the Muder
bound, in particular.
Now again, there's some
games we can play.
Let's ask about the
24, 12, 8 cut.
We've said if we want to realize
it with the cycle-free
realization, this says, well, if
we have a cut that divides
the external variables into
two parts of size 8, then
we're going to be stuck with a
state space of dimension 8 and
a size 256.
No way around it.
Here's a slight way around it.
Let me hypothesize
a realization
that looks like this.
This is a 14, 7 code.
So is this.
We're going to divide the
external variables into three
parts, each of size 8.
And we're going to have three
internal state spaces, each of
dimension 6.
And we're going to constrain
those by an 18, 9 code.
And again, these all have rate
1/2 because this code is dual.
Now, is there anything in what
I've done that prevents this
kind of realization?
Let's test the cut-sets.
Where are the cut-sets in--
well, A, is this cycle-free
realization?
Yes, OK, good.
Let's test the cut-sets.
It's kind of a three-way
symmetrical thing.
The internal cut-sets are
here, here, and here.
Each of these cut-sets divides
the coordinates into one set
of size 8 and one
set of size 16.
In that case, what does the
Muder bound give us?
In that case, 8, 16, the
dimension of the
code is still 12.
The minimum dimension of a code
of length 16 and minimum
distance 8 is 5.
And one of length 8 and minimum
distance 8 is 1.
So as we did on the homework, we
find that we are permitted
to have a state space--
the minimal state space here
could have dimension 6.
So this possibly could occur.
Again, we're kind of
camouflaging some
of the state space.
You see there is no central
state space in this.
There is no cut-set that
partitions it into 12 and 12.
So by being a little bit clever,
we've got it down to
something where instead of a 256
central state space, we've
got three 64 state spaces.
And this is what we saw on the
trellis realization too, that
if we sectionalize into three
sections, then we get a 64
state and a 64 state at the
boundaries between the three
sections, but we still got the
same 512 branch complexity in
the middle.
And what do you know?
We still have a constraint
code with
complexity 512 here, too.
So if you consider that the
more valid measure of
complexity, the minimum
dimension of any constraint
code or branch space, then
we haven't improved.
So subject to these qualifiers,
this is a pretty
strong argument that by going
beyond trellis realizations to
general cycle-free, graphical
realizations, we
can't gain very much.
So the moral is to significantly
reduce
complexity, we're going
to need to go
to graphs with cycles.
We must go to graphs
with cycles.
OK, so you don't get much
for free in this life.
So when we get to our
sum-product decoding
algorithm, we're going to have
to apply it to graphs with
cycles where it's iterative,
where it's not exact, where
it's just a lot less nice.
So what do we do when we go
to graphs with cycles?
Where is the potential gain?
The potential gain is that now
this super-state variable
could be made up of a number
of simpler variables.
We've got a certain minimum
dimension that we're going to
need any cut-set, like 8 for the
central state space of the
Golay code.
But now we can spread it
around over two or more
sub-state variables.
So for instance, maybe we can
find something where we now
have a graph with cycles where
we have two state spaces here.
Here's the cycle again.
And the two state spaces
each have size only 16.
That would still satisfy
this cut-set bound.
So we greatly reduce the size of
the state spaces, which is
exponential in their dimension,
but at the cost of
introducing a cycle.
I insist that's a cycle.
Let's go over to this
trellis here.
The next thing I might talk
about is tail-biting trellis
realizations.
This is very simple.
What's the first realization you
would think of on a graph
with a cycle?
Well, here's a trellis
realization.
It's always going to
look like this.
And then let's just
loop this around.
In other words, we make the last
state space equal to the
first state space.
We don't require they used
to be trivial state
spaces of size 1.
We allow them to have
some dimension.
And here's a potential
realization on a
graph with a cycle.
Cut-sets.
Where are the cut-sets
in this graph?
Well, the cut-sets now
look like that.
All the cut-sets involve
at least two
edges, two state spaces.
OK, so we potentially might
get this kind of benefit.
Here's an example.
Suppose instead, go back to
our very favorite example,
suppose we let u2 go across
here, and we bring out u3 out
of here, and we bring it all
the way back to here.
Everything still good?
It's obviously another
realization.
Now I've made it clear that
when I draw u2 and u3
separately here, I've
really got a cycle.
I've made a big cycle.
And now what's the number of
states in this two-section
realization of the 8, 4 code?
This is a two-state tail-biting
trellis, because
each of these is just a little
binary variable.
So I get some kind of
two-state trellis.
If I were actually to draw out
the trellis, I would have two
states at time 0, two states
at time 4, some kind of --
what have I got--
6, 3.
So I've got 8 branches that go
back and forth, a couple of
parallel branches.
It's going to look like that.
Then same thing out to time 8.
I don't have a time 8.
This is really time 0 again,
where I identify these two
state spaces.
This is really the same state as
this, and this is the same
one as that.
So that's if I really drew out
the trellis in the style I
originally drew trellises,
this would be a
picture of all the--
there's a 1-to-1 map between
all the paths through this
trellis that start and end in
the same state, because that's
what I mean when I identify the
beginning and end states.
So if I start in this state,
there's a four-way branch
here, another four-way
branch there.
Is that right?
No, there's only a two-way
branch such that I can get
back to the initial state.
So there are 8 possible paths
that start here and get back
to the same state, 8 possible
paths that start out from here
and get back to the
same state.
And they together correspond
1-to-1 to all the code words.
OK, well, that's not
a very big deal.
I was able to reduce a
four-state trellis to a
two-state trellis.
But suppose I do the same thing
with the Golay code.
In the Golay code, there's a
very beautiful tail-biting
trellis realization.
It looks like this.
It has 12 sections, so maybe I
won't draw all the sections.
It groups each of the output
variables into pairs and comes
around like that.
And each of these state spaces
has dimension 4, or size 16.
And I give the generator matrix
for this in the notes.
So this is for the 24, 12, 8
code, and now you test me.
Is this a possible--
use the cut-set bound.
See if this violates the
cut-set bound anywhere.
Does it for this code?
No, it doesn't.
Because every cut-set, no matter
how I draw it, we're
going to get two edges, each
with dimension 4, adding up to
a super-state of dimension 8.
And the state spaces at all the
even times, notice I've
sectionalized here, so I only
need to look at even times.
The state spaces at all even
times in this code could have
dimensions as small as 8.
Remember, at the odd times,
they go up to 9.
And these are all little--
4, 4-- these are all
little 10, 5 codes.
So the branch complexity
is only 32.
So this is very much simpler
than any of the conventional
trellises that I've--
than the minimal conventional
trellis that we were able to
draw for this code.
Or if this funny little pinwheel
with three arms on
it, which is also a cycle-free
realization, this code.
OK, so they're going
to tail-biting.
That's a significant advance.
An aside note--
if we just break this, it turns
out we have a generator
matrix that has period 4, and
let this go on infinitely,
this is a realization of a rate
1/2, 16 state, branch
complexity 32, as we expect--
perfectly conventional,
except it's
periodically time varying--
linear convolutional code with
absolutely phenomenal
performance.
Like the Golay code,
it has d equals 8.
Therefore it has a nominal
coding gain of 4, 1/2
times 8, or 6 dB.
This is with only a 16
state, rate 1/2 code.
Look at the ones on the table.
This is significantly
better than that.
And it's effective coding
gain, I forget.
But it's still very good,
excellent, for the complexity
of this code.
So this is called the Golay
convolutional code.
And it's an interesting example
of the interplay
between this block coding stuff
and the convolutional
coding stuff, in this case.
Actually this code was first
discovered in computer
searches, but nobody realized
how wonderful it was.
And it was only when its
connection with this Golay
code was recognized that people
realized this was
really a special code, both
from a performance versus
complexity point of view,
and also algebraically.
OK, well that brings
us to the end.
There's actually one more style
of graph realization
that I want to mention to you,
for the Reed-Muller codes.
We know that they're basically
based on Hadamard transforms.
It's a very nice kind of Fourier
transform like graph
realization of Hadamard
transforms.
So that gives us another style
of realization of Reed-Muller
codes that again, we can
aggregate to lead to a lot of
nice structures.
Again, at the end of the day,
unless we allow cycles, we
don't really gain anything.
So I'll do that the first part
of next time and then do the
sum-product algorithm.
I hope I can do it
in one lecture.